desde hace meses en la ciudad turística
de sousse el periodista independiente
the hand yves xala acecha los
contenedores de desechos italianos desde
la terraza de su oficina que da hacia el
puerto
tal como pueden ver están los
contenedores almacenados en la
plataforma 5 hay 212 que han llegado
desde junio de 2020 y siguen ahí
hace meses que como sociedad civil
peleamos para que regresen al lugar
desde el cual partieron italia
en una publicación en facebook de julio
de 2020 fue el primero en denunciar lo
que ha llamado el escándalo de los
desechos italianos sus contactos en el
puerto jesús le han hecho llegar
documentos y pruebas visuales lo revele
todo con fotos en el interior de los
contenedores el registro fiscal de la
compañía y la naturaleza de los desechos
todo está aquí en fotos en este vídeo
grabado en el depósito se ve que no hay
ninguna máquina para su eventual
reciclaje o su clasificación hay un gran
vacío en noviembre de 2020 las
revelaciones de jambi bensalah fueron
transmitidas en un programa de
televisión tunecino que hizo mucho ruido
abrieron una investigación judicial poco
tiempo después esta sigue en curso
varios ejecutivos de la administración
tunecina son sospechosos de malversación
y la compañía de importación y reciclaje
de desechos cuyo presidente director
general y yo ha sido acusada de
falsificación y fraude 26 personas son
objeto de un proceso judicial 7 siguen
arrestados entre los cuales el ex
ministro del medioambiente despedido al
momento del escándalo
y teme que el caso sea enterrado el
pueblo tunecino quedó sorprendido con
esta historia pero la rabia cayó y
actualmente diez meses después los
desechos siguen ahí
y le diplomacia tunecina ha sido incapaz
de reenviar dichos desechos a su lugar
de origen en efecto en el ámbito
diplomático las cosas avanzan lentamente
entre los dos países que desean arreglar
el asunto amistosamente del lado
italiano la compañía cuestionada sigue
interponiendo recursos ante los
tribunales para alejarse de cualquier
responsabilidad en cuanto a la
repatriación de los desechos esta
profesora de derecho medioambiental en
sfax hace parte de una red asociativa
ecologista túnez verde que lucha para
obtener más información sobre el
expediente nos muestra los diferentes
expedientes por ejemplo ha sido
necesario imprimir leer y traducir las
decisiones en italia el estado tunecino
no informa lo suficiente a la población
tunecina sobre el avance de la situación
la sociedad civil debe presionar
hay que escribir cartas que la red
publica en facebook el estado es el
responsable de este tráfico ilícito
hablamos de italia que tiene la
obligación de retomar dichos desechos en
túnez el caso molestó mucho teniendo en
cuenta que al país le cuesta manejar sus
propias basuras las ciudades están
desbordadas y les faltan recursos
224 millones de toneladas de desechos
ordinarios producidos cada año en su
mayoría son enterrados en rellenos como
aquí en box aquí el más grande de la
capital aquí convergen las basuras de 38
ciudades saturado debería cerrar este
año mira todo esto está lleno esta
representante municipal aún no sabe
dónde podrá ubicar sus desechos en la
ciudad una vez cierran el relleno sí es
cierto que se le encargó a una empresa
reflexionar sobre el post cierre pero no
estamos al tanto de nada actualmente es
como si no hubiese ninguna estrategia de
administración de desechos en túnez este
relleno no es el único que genera
problemas en gamas en la periferia
acomodada de túnez y zona turística un
centro de transferencia de desechos se
volvió un vertedero al aire libre justo
al lado de viviendas y un lago en el
bosque de radés al sur de la capital
jose en handy militante ecologista nos
muestra este vertedero salvaje aquí ve
la montaña de desechos y alrededor mío
hay incluso desechos de construcción
aquí todo el mundo toma el bosque como
un basurero este es un pequeño ejemplo
de lo que ocurre actualmente en el país
y no hay
entre un relleno anárquico como este o
uno controlado
y al final de cuentas son los mismos
impactos en el medio ambiente la manera
en que manejamos los desechos es
bastante catastrófica
frente a estos problemas la sociedad
civil actúa como puede josean dirigió
una asociación para sensibilizar la
clasificación selectiva muy poco
valorizada en el país
hola señora cómo está eso lo viene
en sus dos reunimos con handy y continúa
su lucha por la repatriación de los
desechos italianos
esta es nuestra carpa con los
voluntarios hace varios días que estamos
aquí
estas son canicas en metal las golpeamos
para que nos escuchen
nosotros estamos instalados aquí justo
al lado de la entrada al puerto para
garantizar que ningún contenedor salga y
el tiempo apremia sobre todo para
quienes trabajan en el puerto nuestra
cámara no está autorizada a ingresar
pero un empleado salió a hablarnos esto
no molesta mucho en nuestro trabajo es
por eso que hemos hablado entre el olor
y la sociedad estamos aburridos
el nuevo ministro del medioambiente
habló con confianza de los medios
tunecinos a principios de abril declaró
que el expediente avanza y que los
desechos serán reenviados a italia pero
sin comunicar alguna fecha